what's up guys this is a one-of-a-kind
podcast yeah guys um we're not we
haven't started recording yet or have we
oh we're recording everything never mind
guys um we're we're doing something very
special today not only are we doing our
classic a tree on live stream but we're
also including I'm knife this is the
best part this is only the second thing
we're also including everyone who
supports us at the $3 tier on patreon
now officially and we're also doing a
patreon livestream guest hangout podcast
that's right that's right we got Jake we
got Sam we got Nick we got Scott we got
a computer screen all of our lovely
patrons so everyone who is in this
patreon chat you guys not only are you
gonna be part of this wonderful monthly
conversation that we have with you guys
but we're also gonna be recording this
and turning your questions into a
podcast because we figured a lot of the
things that we talk about on here we get
asked about a lot and we figured hey you
know it'd be better as if we sat down
with our beautiful patrons in an
exclusive patreon only live stream
hangout environment where they spoke
with us and we spoke with them like
podcasts do and then we then recorded
that and distribute it out to the world
later on our YouTube channels and
anywhere podcasts are found perfect um
so that's what we're doing here today
the true tons the truest - the croutons
and the crew and stuff the croutons are
here and so guys guys everyone in the
chat I think this is the first time that
the Internet's ever gonna see a podcast
with I don't know how many people are in
here but record number yeah it should be
like it ever the title of this video
should be like 200 person guessed odd
cast
if the guests less four plus four fifty
four person podcast credit credit real
well before we get any further yeah I
think about you should introduce self
here because you're one of the most
special guests at odd cast yeah tell us
about yourself are you here
the accent people may tell I am British
and I'm the guy that helped build the
watch corridor website Yeah right I'm a
big deal mm-hmm very special too yeah
well he didn't know he was gonna be on
this hangout or this podcast until 15
minutes ago whoo oh you're like guys
you're here you should join us for this
because another thing we're doing today
there's a bunch of people on here from
the $3 tier who were not on the last
patreon livestream hangout because they
weren't at the $5 tier and if you guys
have been poking around on our patreon
page you may have noticed in the $5 tier
well there's something in there it says
what is this was this website membership
what is this well guess what for
everyone at the $3.00 tier and everyone
now listening to this podcast that's
right we've gone and done it
we took YouTube we took patreon and we
combined it into our own website our own
members-only website
yeah now not only do you guys get
everything that we do on YouTube ad free
but we're also gonna be doing site only
shows on our website I'm gonna be
bringing back the vlog first and
foremost yep we've been we actually we
had a good vlog idea the other day but
what what what what was it learning how
to whistle yeah learning how to whistle
in a half-hour
yeah
the American Gothic farmhouse whistle
hey yeah come in come in from the back
you
yeah
yeah my dad you said that whistle yeah
right
the boy feel like this could be turned
into another Ren's mod where he actually
just puts it on a drone and just goes
round mr. Lang goes around people like
old neighborhood hey little drone will
just come come come he has no lie he has
only boys there's like twelve of over
there out in a field somewhere lighting
off okay he flies a drone up and he's
like we got bounced out and they're like
oh dad says come home takes off
oh no dick
and maybe
you
yeah so so anyways um for those of you
who are listening to this podcast we
talked about it uh two months ago or a
month ago how we were gonna do this and
now it's finally live
we're beta testing it right now so if
you guys go to watch corridor comm you
can join our beta website lawn which
means that
which means that we will take your input
Scott and I and Griffin and implement it
into the site now we're gonna be coming
up with a continue watching feed we're
gonna be doing a recommended feed
hopefully yeah hopefully yeah yep it's
actually ready I just need to push the
button to make it our lives oh it is
yeah can you tell a little bit because
we we have all these platforms right now
these days we've got Hulu we've got
Netflix we've got Amazon we've got
YouTube and there's it's it's almost
like a given that there's a recommended
for you
tab I recommend but little did I realize
not being the computer science master
myself that there's actually a ton of
science that goes into these so can you
explain a little bit about like what
these things are and like what you have
to do to build them yeah I mean for the
most part this word gets thrown around a
lot is again it goes back to AI though
I mean there are people that are far
more intelligent than I am but
effectively we take all of your sort of
data points and usage of the website
whether you've you know clicked and
viewed a video whether that's actually
like a full playback or just actually
previewing it and we chuck all of that
into algorithms and we then train on
that data and effectively that then
feeds back in each person that used
website yet to profile so and then we
have so there's no animus profile it is
yes it is it is all anonymous
yes yeah so an anonymous profile and
effectively when you then go to the home
page of the website we then have a
recommended for you and it's gonna take
all of that information and build up a
list of of videos that are that's in the
catalog the ones that it believes is
most relevant to you and it's gonna
return those to you hopefully the more
you use the website the more data we get
on you and then the more relevant your
results will be how do you prevent
people from becoming extremists with
algorithms like that that's always the
question when it comes to recommended
feeds you're turning people into
extremists they're only watching the
things that they want to hear what do
you do one can be done my understanding
is that most people that are using watch
corridor probably already extremists so
you know in for a penny in for a pound
true tones or somebody's Sedalia the
core Dorian's
Christian are we okay technically or
okay do we want to go back and answer
some some initial insights questions and
what-have-yous yeah the audio input
mixer that is recording all the
microphones is only able to output two
channels to the PC so you guys I think
might be being picked up as background
or the podcast but for the podcast I'm
sorry for the for the for the live
stream for the podcast we're all being
recorded though okay um
unless yeah just well here's another
thing we're doing right now we're
effectively live podcasting for the
first time ever so man you know I wish I
was a corridor patron like cuz wait
you're not I mean I am just I subscribe
oh we've done so many cool things this
month we've dropped we dropped the live
hangout down to the $3 tier we're doing
a live podcast for the first time we
dropped a website membership you know
that's all stuff that we've been talking
about doing for like three years yeah
that we've actually done this month yeah
and last month it's super cool I'm just
really curious to see how the website
changes what we do in studio that's a
really huge thing mostly just cuz we
were talking about this last week on the
or last month on the live stream but you
know the idea of a lot of the content we
make right now is very much suited to be
put on YouTube and it's tailored towards
that ecosystem and that algorithm which
is basically just how many people can
you get to click on this video and now
generally when you're making content
that's a really good lima thinking how
do you mix the popular good train of
thought yeah but at the same time you
know it doesn't it doesn't necessarily
reward like loyal audiences so to speak
of people who are really passionate
about a certain piece of content or
things like that sometimes you then have
to pass it up for other opportunities
because the view count is
you know kind of up to par ecosystem
doesn't monetize certain types of
content yeah other ecosystems do and
ever and I'd like to answer this because
we've been getting a lot of questions
legitimate question from friends from
fans from other people that we've been
working with asking us why why are you
guys trying to do your own website
member mm-hmm legitimately why are you
trying to do this there's YouTube
there's all these other social media
platforms there's floatplane there's
people and companies that have tried to
do their own website subscription
platform and failed time and again why
are you doing this and I'd like to
answer that because I think it's
legitimately the first question that you
should ask it's the first question that
we should understand and the thing about
what we're doing is we're not doing it
like everybody just like we've done with
corridor we're not doing it like
everybody else and I don't just mean
like hey our content is special no I
mean like the actual fabric of what
we're doing is different than the way
that traditional subscription services
are set up and built this subscription
service grows as its audience growth
not something where we took on and this
is something we should talk about it the
previous cost of what it caught used to
cost to build these things but we can
get into that in a second but previously
you were gonna go out and start a
subscription s vaad right subscription
video on-demand service you had to go
out you had to get a bunch of venture
capitalists together you had to license
a bunch of content from videos what have
you did you get all that together and
then build this platform and then all of
a sudden be like okay guys go we've got
two million dollars were burning X
amount of money per month and we need to
get X amount of subscribers in order to
become profitable by X date but the
thing that we've done with this site
through God's incredible talents has
been the patreon support that we're
receiving is currently paying for the
costs of the site itself now obviously
we don't want the site to just be our
patrons even though you guys are well
the best what we want is as this as
people learn about this and as people
start to use it
the $3.99 that is paid for the five
dollars that's paid you get special
special things on patreon that money now
all the sudden creates an ecosystem that
supports content that otherwise wouldn't
be yeah we wouldn't have an ecosystem
available to produce and so it's not a
question of well if we don't get X
amount of subscribers after X amount of
time the thing fails it's a question of
because like previous sites have done
which is why they've failed
if it if we have
thousand people on this thing then we'll
make the type of content that supports
that that ecosystem yeah we have 50,000
well guess what we can make bigger shows
yeah and and it scales up and down
from this point right now because it's
already breaking even and so the
question of like why are you guys doing
this it's twofold number one we want
another outlet other than YouTube and we
don't and I'm not talking about Facebook
and Instagram and those are great right
but like they're owned operated and
brand guidelines and ad revenue taken
and ecosystem supported by these other
huge companies you don't necessarily
just want to run off and go okay here
yeah
right
right right
if you guys are interested in a website
consider heading on over to
squarespace.com IRS's now that's but
that's literally like half my half of my
talent contribution now to the corridor
crew channel if not more probably a
hundred percent at this point is being
the [ __ ] brand guy and don't get me
wrong I love it yeah it's fun to like
it's like Oh Jake your life's so hard
you got to get up every day and go in
front of an audience of a million people
and speak oh I'm sorry you know but like
yeah I'm not gonna [ __ ] about it it's
[ __ ] awesome but like at the same
time maybe we don't have to do
you know it's always a pleasure coming
up with funny brand deals it is it's
actually like one of the highlights yeah
and people really like them and thank
you guys for yeah like always being
vocal in the comments when our
integrations weren't good because it
made us better at them
but I think so two things before we get
into like the costs of like how to build
one of these things and why why it's
different now actually maybe we should
answer that question now just briefly
like we were just having this
conversation oh all of a sudden being
able to build and scale a global
platform is different than it has ever
existed in the previous history of the
internet why in Amazon really yeah so
the you know and cloud of two words that
always get thrown around yeah so even as
you know as little as six years ago
which in technology is actually almost
10 times that it's a whole generation
level generation but you know if you
look back at those early days Amazon had
a problem which is that they used to buy
tons of servers and that would surface
let's say 10,000 people per hour problem
that they had is that Christmas would
come along suddenly they need to surface
you know to serve 60,000 people rights
they'd buy all the servers to look after
60,000 people and some genius I read
Amazon said hey well we need to have
60,000 servers but for most of the year
50,000 of them aren't doing anything
they made Amazon Web Services and what
that has allowed people like us to do is
basically use tupelo cost servers that
are on demand or reserved for a year or
longer and and we can just em them off
you know turn them on turn them off
whereas previously we had to do what
Amazon were doing which is by rivers
three four five servers no fur usually a
year-long contract each server is gonna
be costing you you know there could be
six $700 pounds per month that's quite a
commitment and then no it's actually one
of the interesting things is on the last
livestream that we did is somebody said
hey Jake how many people did this
support and you're like it's about to
3,000 well yeah the answer is actually
because we use Amazon we catch
scale we automatically scale yeah so
theoretically we could be dealing with
10,000 people using the site
simultaneously and and it will support
that know if if 10,000 people will lock
you know signing all at the same time
might cause a little bit of a problem
yeah please don't all sign in and Melton
people you know do it we will do it if
we get to that problem I will be
clapping my hands and shaking hands and
I am buying you a nice bottle of wine
Oh that'd be nice very nice couple of
bottles of wine just a couple okay so
yeah it's it's it's allowed you know
small companies like mine to come in and
help you guys and other people to know
at a low cost
up a solution you know get a feel for it
so we've been able to launch two hundred
patreon two hundred plus yeah and then
hopefully after this Oh cast video and
other announcements on patreon another
two thousand and then you know and then
in over a month two months time go to
the wider audience yeah and you know and
our costs are scaling with our user base
so it really makes it visible that's
that's what I'm saying it's like you add
in the the technology that's available
with the approach to the site and all of
a sudden this thing that was cumbersome
and shut down all these joint venture
ventures previously and was impossible
to do now all the sudden becomes
feasible yeah which is great also
point out it sounds like it's not just
Amazon sounds like Jesus is actually the
reason why this is possible because
Christmas created the supply Christmas
comes from G and just saying hey what do
you know how do you argue with that
logic alright let's go to the patrons
here and at first think we should just
go through and guys if you were at the
$5 tier or are at the $5 tier and you've
been using the site first and foremost
get us up let us know in the comments of
the livestream what you thought what we
can do better what you know this is just
oh yeah hey right now I already saw one
which was that a little demand to get
the uploads YouTube and the site a
little mostly a little more closely
synced so this problem we have an
uploader but it failed it failed last
night
and it was working and it could just be
something got turned off or whatever but
we haven't we have a scheduler on the
videos and when the videos go up
we I upload them at the same time I blow
them to youtube and then I set the time
that they go live and I've been setting
the ones on the site to go live two to
three hours before YouTube oh cool um
but and then what's supposed to happen
is that the as the time in actual space
time passes the time in the scheduler
the video automatically publishes but
this this feature seems to be sometimes
working and sometimes not you know why
that would be is it just we're working
on it yeah yeah I mean I mean
fundamentally it's you know I think it's
one of those things where we've spent a
lot of time really focusing on getting a
good high quality website applications
you know we've been uploading videos I
mean missions fo on that front has been
incredible I mean he's done the entire
back catalogue of everything and then
something we rolled into the sort of the
the betta period and the live period and
now we're coming across the teething
issues of you know getting our videos in
sync with YouTube and maybe even before
YouTube so yeah definitely wanted to be
before YouTube yeah but only by a few
hours I don't think it's realistic to at
this point to like try to do that so
it's it's definitely something that
we're gonna work on I mean my open plan
is to commit a lot more time to this
over the next couple of weeks
certainly so that in the next two or
three weeks will be where we need to be
so
yes appreciate the feedback and you know
we are we are working on it oh yeah
long story long story short we are going
to the plan is to continually upload raw
to the website a few hours prior to
YouTube and obviously then we are also
going to be having sight only vlogs that
are gonna be starting on the site
probably when the site goes public
Oh public as in like not just the truest
of the Teutons or the croutons who are
the podcasters and the true tongues who
are the a tree owners oh not just you go
down sit on corridor crew and we
announce it did I mean globally we
should make a whole video about this
on-quarter crew and really like you know
I'm really excited to bring back the
vlog or whatever that will turn into it
never is gonna be the showrunner yeah I
mean yeah I mean that's what brought me
well yeah we should just throw this out
there okay you know how we did a we're
hiring video and Carmichael nice we're
gonna be doing part two in that due in
part to keep an eye out on you guys are
editors your editors out there and you
want to be the person who
brings the vlog back ya see my see Mike
- yes Mike - we uh we need someone to do
that because everyone is at full
capacity right now it's really hard to
do ya know in the best way the best way
but be able to capture and like really
tell the story of the day-to-day here is
something that needs someone dedicated
and also like I don't know have you
thought of any other like types of
exclusive content we could do for this
well there's the we kind of experimented
this with this actually with the last AI
dungeon video mm-hmm
but the idea would be like a D&D style
series we cool that's supported by a
live-action interpretation of what's
happening in the game basically what we
did with AI dungeon but a little bit
more behind it yeah there's a story and
production yeah
honey what about we've been throwing
around the idea of doing like these is
uh this isn't a brand segment but skill
shares around the studio you know we're
gonna have like you know if any member
of the crew has something that they're
they want to kind of share exactly steel
studies I mean that could be a viable
video format like just have people kind
of sit down for 10 minutes
talk to the camera about you know
something could be valuable Matt again
perfect example of a type of format that
doesn't work that well on YouTube some
people have made success at it like
that's how Peter McKinnon started I was
like yeah photo tutorial stuff but by
and large that stuff doesn't give you
what YouTube likes which is like a
recurring regular audience that's there
to watch you and your show rather than
like hey I'm just here for the tutorials
man stop talking about your dog you know
yeah like that that's a different type
of audience and and when you're doing
tutorials yeah that's the type of
audience that you bring in is the how
tours we're just passing through and we
have the opposite problem I think on our
channel is like yeah we put out a
tutorial people are like why are you
doing that yeah I don't want that so a
YouTube so again that's a perfect
example of something that should go on
the site rather than on YouTube and then
if people really find that valuable
$3.99 yeah you sign up for a month watch
all the videos to turn it off
I guess a big problem you have on
YouTube is the auto crew is such a
wide-ranging set of things which is I
guess when you explain why no you guys
having knowed now means that you can
take what was previously fun and games
on crew and move it across whereas the
website now gives you that capability to
go hey here are all of the individual
channels without creating the guillotine
channel and cars channel and you know
you could end up with 1015 channels and
a diminished subscriber base or you know
that where everybody has to go through
and subscribe to everything whereas with
the website no maybe we can even look at
a notification feature where people can
can get out notifications for each
individual Channel or something so it's
it is more direct if you want those or
no it's just yeah helps share that load
we just need to ask you guys can tell us
I saw somebody asking about if there's
going to be apps for the site
apps are ready they're ready we sort of
didn't quite get through all of the App
Store approvals for the last livestream
so the links are available in the menu
on the website we have both iOS and
Android
I also saw somebody asked about maybe in
chromecast and Apple TV those are also
being worked on you have a long list of
features a lot of which have been
suggested by by the various people that
have emailed in which again there's a
link where you can send us a message
provide feedback which has been
tremendous actually I wish I had a list
of all the people I could shout out for
you know providing you know really good
feedback
you know they've gone through the
various steps of issues it's been really
fantastic we thank you Alex just
installed the Google Play version who
works great yep I also have the Google
Play version I'm a Droid guy
everybody like the only one in the
office it was like hey have you tested
this and everybody knows it download the
iPhones
what other questions or comments did we
get on the website
be here
okay
what's the main message we're aphek to
the main method we're gonna be using to
drive traffic to the site is is YouTube
we have an audience obviously across its
probably how you found us is probably on
YouTube beat skippin
you know we've got the podcast here
we've got the crew channel we've got
node we've got the corridor channel we
can use all those to tell the audience
that hey if you guys like these videos
you can find more of this right over
here um and again I don't expect
everybody to subscribe I'm not trying to
get everybody in the world or everybody
even in our audience to buy into this
thing I just want the people that care
about it and want more to get that and
to have it scale in a way that doesn't
like open us up to like obvious gaps for
failure it's those true tones man it's a
sanctuary for the truth it really is it
really is we should have a whole like
entry true tones you've already got all
the filters from you know one of the
videos the other day welcome home we
should have seven eco green screened as
elements like green screen to enter
great green screen across the double
doors and just get them on a rope you
know them from the balcony
been a long-standing goal Arab Sam Sam
Gorski calm that's a text endeavour and
it's all intertwined I think oh yeah can
we have a secret link in the website
like something where it takes you to Sam
Gorski calm yeah like short answers keep
an eye out it might be out there right
now yeah are you going to upload live
streams to the site but those that miss
them um yeah actually I think that's a
good idea that I didn't think about
doing until literally right now and I
read that sentence well you did but like
six months ago
so yeah that's right because we did the
live feature yeah that's right oh man
rough to sort that out for the next one
yeah well eventually we want to start
using the live the live feature on the
website for these hangouts but yeah long
story short cables we are going to be
uploading the live streams to the site
for those
I think Pete Suarez has a very good
point here a second that motion
dition to add and that we custom max
cursor with just a little pool cue my
god he's got he's got his little tried
what does dobby carry I think I sharpen
broken Betty Harris ridin gets more
grand well I think you had a t-shirt or
something or oh yeah we're the Trident
III have put in the request to Griffin
who's been doing a lot of the design
work an amazing job as well to design a
Dobie 404 landing page so there we go
Damaris and Dobie Dobie Millia
the site's just broken for a minute yeah
yeah or if it's have a buffering he just
comes along goes haha Jake speaking of
site features did you do Griffin show
you that elevator pitch thing because I
think elevator pitch oh he's I don't
have a chance to look at it yet so I
mean I don't know if you want to I mean
I don't know all about this so maybe if
you can explain more but like I heard
there's gonna be the ability or like the
crew members to kind of pitch their
ideas to the website the project
features yeah yeah projects this is
another thing that we haven't rolled out
yet in the beta that Griffin and Scott
are working on currently that I'm gonna
get ready for public launch but
basically
you pay 399 for this site or $5 if
you're on patreon because it Buhler
stuff and what we do is we take that
money and we turn that into points and
then we say hey how much does it cost to
do a D&D show with live-action content
well it costs about this much okay well
then we need X amount of points to
contribute to that project in order for
that project to be greenlit and if
enough people that use the site in
tribute their points to that project we
will make that project it's cool so
we're gonna put out projects that like
obviously projects that we want to make
as we're making them yeah but basically
whichever ones get greenlit through the
members are the ones that will do that's
very cool man that's another thing
that's different about this site then
it's like gotta got a little bit of a
Kickstarter like element in there but
really for well let's the fans like
actually choose what they want to watch
for real like more than a patreon poll
of right what should we react to next
you know like which is great by tangible
your money can actually this is the
adult version make our content yeah
that's awesome grown version
what is the corridor endgame theatrical
film TV series or more bigger so I can
get back that may be something else
um this is it yeah I mean I think we're
we're kind of good with not being part
of the traditional film industry because
basically just a bunch of like blowing
smoke up each others butts so to speak
seriously though it's it's it's a huge
giant web of executives and I think
we've found a way to make things yeah
outside of that and the end game is
continuing to make cool things outside
of that system and at whatever scales
yeah let me let me soften the blow for
those of you who might be in the
traditional industry on that and expand
upon that because basically
there's a lot of good things that have
come from obvious I'm a good thing are
worse or yeah a Star Wars but it has its
own it has its own way of doing things
and there are some people who are
extremely efficient at understanding
that system and being effective in that
system
Andy Shankar uh-huh bunch of other
people that we know but for what we do
and the types of videos that we like to
make that system isn't idyllic for us
and so you've gone off into this other
tangent doing what we want doing the
videos that we love obviously the one
thing that digital media up to this
point has limited is if dollar spend per
minute on content now with something
like the site or thinking about things a
little bit outside of the box there are
avenues as the digital media industry
and the digital media platforms begin to
solidify and create true ecosystem can
participate in the avenues for thinking
outside of that box to bring in more
more dollars per minute begin to open
and over time we're gonna continue to
see that happening and
quite frankly the goal is just to ride
that wave and to continue to expand
creatively into whatever types of ideas
we like and whatever types of the ideas
the dollars will support
so I guess this is my question for Sam
then is because something like lifeline
you know there's kind of I mean I
enjoyed it I know a lot of people did as
well you guys don't always look at it in
the best of light do you feel like if
that had been you know a watch corridor
project that it could have been
different and like how do you measure
the success and failure of a corridor
video
oh so that's yeah it's kind of like two
questions yes yes the like the measure
of success
right now is on YouTube ultimately it is
views because that's where we've been
posting all the videos for the last ten
years so so that's really the main
judgments like what's the response how
many people are watching this is this
catching on right example those Boston
Dynamics videos it was happened to be a
great like middle like you know
intersection of here's an idea we're
really passionate about and a lot of
people liked watching it yeah or liked /
disliked watching it regardless they
watched it so there's there's that
element with the website the measure of
success changes certainly because we can
go after a you know a different audience
so to speak the net doesn't have to be
as wide necessarily for better for worse
but but we'll see what that changes and
then the first question was like the
will be the experience yeah I mean well
I mean like really it just it started
really just at the beginning which is
like it was it was a challenge because
it was just simply it's the total
opposite style of what we do on the me
in a day you know you don't it'sit's
weird cuz you know they're like these
are like filmmakers and have a YouTube
channel and we'll make a series that
gets posted on your YouTube channel and
the really the main issue is just right
from the beginning you know Nikko myself
we shoot a lot of this stuff ourselves
you know we there's a very hands-on
approach we're used to the smaller team
element and we kind of thrive in that
and so immediately that whole trajectory
of like a smooth production was thrown
off when basically we are thrust into
the world of you know the Hollywood
industry in the film unions and like one
of the first orders that we got on the
project is that we literally could not
touch a camera girls someone would get
fined or the Union would like strike
basically so so like that mount that set
off like kind of a chain of events that
eventually made it so I practically was
like lethargic on the set in the entire
time because it's like there's literally
nothing I can do here except like talk
to actors every once in a while and I
still have like two or three like
executives from the YouTube side or like
the production company side who are like
trying to like change things constantly
and it's like it's like not only do you
have less control because you're less
involved with it but you have less
control because there's now another
dozen people who are actively making
decisions above your head about the
project that you have no control over so
you you have a lack of control on all
sides and so it's so so those projects
end up like now that I see it
from that perspective it's like the
success of big projects are are really
just the some of the team that's working
on it can all these people in Kent can
twelve decision-makers work together
rather than like at our studio which is
a project can two or three
decision-makers work though right
and the only problem with lifeline we
were thankful for the experience and
yeah it was great like understanding
more about a television Ironmen cuz that
was that was stock you to basically
going we have no idea what we're doing
we are going to we want content so how
do we get content well there's the whole
blueprint from the television industry
that we can just copy they literally
just copied that and and that was kind
of weird because they're you know
they're taking a format that exists
elsewhere and going hey we're gonna make
put it on a youtube channel now it's
like well that's why that's why YouTube
got rid of YouTube red yeah cuz we were
applying a TV format didn't report it
none of the shows did well you know they
were like this isn't going anywhere like
this is this group of people isn't
functioning right now so because it's
platt it's a system it's not like when
TV was invented a bunch of producers
from the film industry sat around and
went okay guys how do we apply film onto
television they were like hey what is
this medium oh you can do this with it
you can do this with it oh okay the
first television was was basically just
visual radio right you know like yeah
so so like the whole like cinema world
and you know cameras and roll you know
right film camera like they weren't
there wasn't anything like that on there
it took time before like that style of
content found its own like transition
and that created a modus operandi for
television what is now known as
television production and the type of
content that you get with television
productions formed because of that it
wasn't like they knew that that existed
and then came in and applied it later
and so there should be no reason to
think that that should all of a sudden
work on digital yeah we are on the
internet when it totally again a
different thing that needs to have its
own time it's only better video content
creation on the internet has really only
been around since 2005 yeah exactly I
mean the only similar 13 years yeah I
mean the only similarities are that like
it's a moving image with four right
angles in the frame yeah i'm dottie oh
yeah and anthem audio yeah those are the
similarities but so we're just trying to
I just want to keep like finding out
what that
what our version of that is like what
our modus operandi is for how we should
do things to create and tell story and I
feel like we've been doing that and I
feel like we should continue to do that
I watch the vlog I saw I don't know what
you guys were doing on the channel but I
saw some of the old patreon blooper
reels from like yeah three or four years
ago and I watched those last night man
those are so funny
those are so ridiculous and it's just
like others say look we can do for the
website yes but I look at what we are
doing three years ago and I'm like wow
we would never do this [ __ ] now you know
it's just changed man need a good end up
yeah and we will kiss the crew channel a
good end a bittersweet way but your
question though like do you think that
with the website it would like say you
guys wanted to make lifeline would you
again yeah okay would you have like the
resources with this website it say like
like how many how many people members do
you think it would take to get us to the
point where we can create like long-form
narrative content or short form their
content I don't have the number I've
done rough math on this and this is
trust me this is rough math but
basically it it allows us to continue to
produce like YouTube like shows with a
little bit more behind them up to like
the fifty thousand swords member range
and then after like fifteen thousand
members it starts to become like real
money that you can put into shows that
have this higher cost crazy like even
competing with quality of you know
Netflix maybe or whatever not competing
just like well at the making yeah you
know I mean yeah man that's really cool
gonna be so much freedom yeah so it's a
I don't expect 15,000 people to just
sign up for this site like I have
realistic expectations thousand people
did I would be overjoyed but in time as
we proved the format as we prove the
shows that are on there I hope that more
and more people will see the value of it
just like more and more people have seen
the value of what we've done on crew and
what we've done in corridor and what
we've done on all this all the videos
that we've made I'm here
I remember one corridor digital YouTube
had 700 thousand subs i hack I remember
what it was that like 400 I think I
subscribed it like 19 k after you guys
put out that that first video holy days
Wow
and it was like modern warfare yeah and
then I was like we put it on Freddie's
channel and I was it like up 20 K yeah
but there was like a link to your
channel like we didn't I don't think the
champ no the channel resistance
what else we got any questions a
dressen's from the patrons
oh here we go
question about the corridor app we're
just talking about this cause there'd be
a future setting for video notifications
yes yes technically it is in place do I
just need to click that box it says pop
publish on both yes and yeah you can
like type in the fields and click the
buttons and then hit go and then send
both then it'll send to iOS and Android
so I can start doing that yeah so again
it's just another one of those like this
is a new format uh everybody here and
we're hopefully gonna slowly learn how
the platform works and just videos
coming out more smoothly and you're
sending out notifications as well I mean
in theory we can get it so that when it
publishes it automatically sends one out
yeah that's right it's in beta right now
because this is the yeah okay I can
start doing that now then yeah button
remove it definitely you know keep
suggesting things a lot of people do
suggest the same features and things and
it's it goes into a you know a long list
of improvements and we prioritize it so
um and I try to reply to everybody that
emails in so um we are listening well we
got a couple questions here will there
be a lag versus the youtube uploads like
well videos be uploaded after youtube
uploads you get like a lag in yeah we
had but yeah that's just because of
growing pains right now getting this
system figured out ideally you were
saying we want there to be a lag in the
YouTube content versus the website right
we want to upload that after yeah so the
video today that came out on crew in
about 15 minutes after YouTube but that
was because the publisher didn't auto
publish and so I double-checked it and I
manually everybody in the like every
other one that we've done this week has
been published prior to last week
um not so much but yeah now they're
gonna be coming out basically two hours
before is the short is right answer was
before on the website is correct me if
I'm wrong but actually a lot of the
videos you you literally get the render
finished produce the files and then it
goes straight up so yeah you know there
can't be a two or three-day gasps
otherwise unless unless you just stopped
like three days right we could win a
backlog everything it hit up some of
these questions here and screen a couple
we use the website to show some of the
individual projects like Sam's music or
anything maybe maybe not sometimes those
individual projects are kind of done
those little personal things the album's
I'm releasing are are kind of in that in
that vein right now where I'm just doing
that my personal time so probably not on
the site but you know they're also on
Spotify which is ideal for music
listening so one can listen to that
Tyler 404 your question is kind of
similar to the one Sam just answered
about like kind of doing a little deep
dives into people's yeah I think yeah I
think that's everyone can share very
different elements this you know plant
Nick Christian Jake you know so well
yeah we we we are thinking about trying
to start the kind of a you know
skilled not skill sure what we were
calling it skill spots studies so to
speak we're trying to we're gonna start
with them a little more focused on a
little more of our day-to-day so what
we're doing in the studio yeah a little
more functional and once we kind of get
over that will kind of dive into more
varied topics
I know Clint or Jan want to do a yoga
participant improvement one because
they're really into that cliffs an
instructor Clips the mystery yoga
instructors in the studio yeah so yeah
or all the livestreams gonna be like
this from now on or is the pot just
podcast format I don't know maybe maybe
not sometimes sometimes not sometimes
it's good to get the whole studio in
there and just so yeah I definitely
don't want to lose doing doing patreon
Oh
lene just exclusive everyone in the
studio the sort of vibe that we have on
the previous ones but at the same time
well if the live stream is only once a
month oh yeah yeah odd cast is a little
bit more work on it also I think we have
some technical issues too still sort out
as you're highly aware of but uh but
yeah yeah are y'all working on tactical
yes there's tactical three loads there's
tactical four loads and five loads yeah
that we have we have scripts for
basically all of them very best part are
the titles
there's tacticool three loads and then
there's tactical reloads where all the
A's are four and then there's tactical
reloads where the S is a five after that
we haven't figured it back to cool three
loads is about or film ready we're
framing it we're two weeks filming it in
two weeks with Matt best yeah and it's
basically Nico and Freddie are these
showboating reloaders when a super
tactical Keanu Reeves fan joins the club
and reloads in under a second and they
are just super ticked off that this guy
has no style and he's all substance yeah
tactical for loads is about Freddie and
Nico meeting their their their sensei
their hero who's like the guy who got
them into reloading in the first place
yeah at a convention and in a moment of
need they have to save and impress them
impress their sensei with their
reloading - Wow - to win a one on one
dinner date with him
tactical five loads is about Nico and
Freddie facing off against Dee from the
very first episode once again and he's
gotten so good at reloading that big
aside the only way to defeat him is to
take a time machine back to the past and
kill him as a child
in doing so nico accidentally reloads in
front of Reddy's young mother who hasn't
had Freddie AHA and wins her heart so
Freddie must teach his past father to
reload and be a gunslinger his mom's
heart so that way Freddy can be born
so um yeah that that's a really really
fun series and it's super fun to write
because no matter what you do it's
always new because it's reloading yeah
can you reload time anyway yeah here's a
weird question what's your favorite
bridge yeah that's one's got a bridge
they once went over and do I just say
London Bridge I mean it's I mean is that
your favorite really I mean music your
English heritage requires you to say
London I mean I like San Francisco
Bridge I was up I was up at Berkeley and
that's just this Golden Gate Bridge
yeah Golden Gate Bridge and you just got
this beautiful view of the bridge and it
damaged big well there's pontiff in in
Paris
on that bridge oh there's the Stillwater
lift bridge Stillwater lift bridge and
then there's the stone bridge
oh the stone or a bridge the oldest
bridge shown a bridge in Minnesota yeah
which is where we filmed sasses Creed 3
revelation so serve some my favorite
riches I have one very special bridge
there's a in the Japanese tea garden in
a home Gate Park I've been on that very
but there's a really steep
any little arch bridge that has those
little hand holds it's so steep it's
this is an advanced this is an expert
level bridge you should go there and
check it out don't bring
like this is a good blog if you go
around what's a favorite bridge yeah
like you go around and ask people what
their favorite bridge is on bridge fact
about the Golden Gate Bridge has never
been fully painted because well they're
always repainting it yeah yeah they
never can stop repainting that bridge is
the salt just keeps eating the pain away
it was just always some guy who's like
man like goes through generations yes
like my father's father bridge and also
apparently the color that they painted
the Golden Gate Bridge is like unique to
the bridge like there's no other shade
of orange like this is the time like
they chose it they like concocted this
but now you can just do a hex analysis
in right yeah listen Meghan I wonder if
their paint was was made in the paint
powder factory right next door in this
building I very welcome
if our fans have video content would we
be able to hire us to work on it and
perhaps feature that work on without if
I shoot it over to our contact email
right now contact record or digital yeah
sure yeah and we will analyze it they
are looking for very specific projects
to potentially give a little bit of a
makeover so to speak pimp will pimp them
up a little bit my movie hitch the
series yeah I mean we so we saw this I
think Kenyon YouTube channel went viral
and it's been happening for years oh by
the way they're making badass movies
over there but their effects are a
little bit lacking prepare don't like
you know it's raw energy of course like
the movies are just pure energy and its
really eight [ __ ] and it's amazing but
we're like man that would be awesome if
we could like get in there and like do
some shots for one of their movies and
just like take it to the completion but
we also were thinking we get emails all
the time from you know fans from random
people who see our videos and like I
want to hire you can you do you know the
effect for me I have liked this film
yeah and I don't know how to do this
shot can you do it and we can't because
we get so many of them and we really
didn't
now I'll edit my sex at corridor digital
comm some exist yet I think it does
we're gonna ask people to submit their
videos with the caveat that we can we
will spend one day just one day doing
whatever we possibly can and want and
want to that video the changes would
maybe creative changes but they have to
be permanent
yes my pimp my video yes and the idea is
we do it regularly and eventually if
it's got enough people that enjoy it we
bring an exhibit wow these are some big
promises Jake first the website then
exhibit if the video if the show does
well we're like two degrees above
exhibit right now we have to work our
way back Jake is teaching he could
already be a crouton
yeah so I'm super excited for that to
communicate our bridge not evil reloads
oh man that's hilarious reloading a
fricken yeah we go further back in time
and they have bows and arrows their bows
and arrows and oppressor princess Robin
Hood I mean I don't know how you every
Lotus means for whatever it's Nottingham
Forest a real place yeah oh yeah yeah
they don't just make needs a bomb in
movies and stuff have you been there
yeah it's like probably the only tourist
destination in Nottingham let's let's
get some hard-hitting questions here
guys we want the hard-hitting question
what's your favorite VR game I don't
know mark Roomba is trying to do the
walking it is like it kind of does the
bone works thing but a little bit
smoother there gonna be some is burning
I did the climbing mechanics and some of
the grip mechanics and bone works are
like are definitely cooler but the
Walking Dead has slightly less features
but the polish on it is it's it's pretty
good honest reviews think about bone
works that I love is that you don't feel
stuck to anything you know feel stuck to
the ground
yeah no you don't like feel like you're
being led through a path so I got a
little bit more as I should lately but
that's just my initial Corrections I
feel like you guys need to collab and
get a like tactical reloads minigame
within bone works I've seen Dee do some
cool stuff in it so I feel like there's
a potential
yeah requires lots of slow motion
equipment do you use for your live
streaming setup 7 B's these are best in
the business right here testing any sort
of these metal poles that pull these
cables let's not talk about this because
no I mean you can thing is you can kind
of use anything you want but the main
thing is you'd have a good interface
with your computer and good microphone
and I'm getting all these questions
about my music this is this is yeah well
it's coming out in a few months we'll
see it Casey Casey's mixing and
mastering it all right now and it sounds
like so thick and heavy and it's like
wow that was more talented man like a
butter churn
yeah and heat cuz like it's metal there
just look at metal genre so so that
usually those mixes are kind of flat
because there's a lot going on it's
super fast so it makes them flat to like
make make it able to you make you able
to hear everything but Casey kind of has
that more cinematic soundtrack style of
mixing things so he's got it's just like
this that sick wave where but you can
still hear everything so it's really
cool he's very talented what's the best
advice you've ever received
that one
all right high school track coach hey
mr. Scott Kristiansund man whoo man who
had 23 pupils run the mile in under 4
minutes that everybody wants to go easy
go you guys I hear all you guys out
there on your training runs and you're
always complaining about how Oh running
hurts oh I don't want to do it anymore
well guess what I Got News for you
everybody wants to go to heaven but no
one wants to die and that's honestly the
best advice I've ever heard in my life
because it's true for everything
everybody wants success everybody wants
blah blah blah everybody wants out of
the DA but they don't want to have to do
the painstaking work that's required to
do it myself included I'm just as much
of a jackass as everyone else yeah I
think about that sometimes when I'm
being a little [ __ ] about stuff and I'm
like yeah but sometimes I just got to do
it you know I think that's a fantastic
advice but you know the counterpoint to
that advice is you know maybe sometimes
your your doubt in the afterlife will
maybe you know uh help you have a better
time on earth you have doubt in the
afterlife I'm just saying every once in
a while you have to go it's okay I'm
going to heaven and then everyone said
well we have to go like I need some me
time I'm going to hell no that's what
you have to say sorry actually that much
clearer you know we're going to hell
today pizza all right I'm not showering
all right
[Music]
anybody else any other girls I don't
think I'm the best advice like I
wouldn't say it was advice but it's you
know I'd rather work an eight it well
I'd work at an 80 hour work week or void
working a 40-hour workweek that just
goes back into like like if you can work
twice as hard for something that you
you're passionate about it beats the
hell out of working for you know
somebody else doing something you don't
enjoy it's like it's like follow your
passion I mean pretty sure this is how
corridor digital has done so well is
that you know it's about passion
projects you know passionate why are you
doing it entrepreneurs will work 80
hours a week to avoid working 40 yeah
yeah I mean it's like and it's not even
like if you even it's not even about
doing it for yourself it's like even if
it's just something that you enjoy being
good at so to speak or something that
you're really interested in it's like
I've noticed that too with you know
occasionally we do these projects for
other people like you know the black
rifle guys and he's the commercial we
did with them it's like even though
that's not even going on our Channel
it's still like I'm still we're still
doing the stuff that way and really
enjoying your looks you know you're
willing to give it two or three hundred
percent because it's something even even
if it's not the specific project you're
passionate about it just it's the craft
yeah hey guys Ren just joined us Justin
was nosy here share the microphone here
undo that little Tommy and the streamers
around the yeah we're using that OBS
today and our audio input is not giving
us yeah well the channel I guess we've
ever done
oh you really have to man poisoning
that's awesome it's that's the extreme
vape stuff that they keep complaining
about oh gosh the coding ish okay but
good news is that I didn't actually ever
burn out the whole really two questions
as the patrons have asked us all to
answer first question once a channel you
want to collaborate with oh it's gonna
be what's your favorite bridge second
question what's your favorite bridge
third question what's the received third
question what's the best advice you've
ever received it's over the River Kwai
never give up my man also it is what it
is that's not good advice
that's cop-out it but it's two sides of
the same coin it's opposite advice to
each it's important to keep in mind
I've forbade myself from using the
phrase that is whether it is even though
I I do understand what that it's a good
phrase
we'll forgive but don't forget thing you
know like it be be yeah kind and like
understanding but you know just but
someone does he wrong put it in your
pocket and you go so you don't make that
mistake I'm all about forgetting but not
forgiving no I do I need to remember the
name of it but there's a really
fascinating like I guess it's this
philosophical thing about yeah what is
it you can't even describe it it's so
cool but up it comes down to the idea of
like alright you do you forgive someone
or do you hold a grudge or do you hold
like how do you retaliate you know or or
if someone wrongs you and a lot of like
kind of like that you can actually take
that and put it down into basically in
an equation or an algorithm of like how
do you respond or how do you act in life
and you can actually like
algorithmically figure out what the best
way to handle day-to-day interactions is
because if you live your life always
retaliating against people who wronged
you
and never forgiving then basically what
you end up doing is you put yourself in
lose-lose situations I think it was the
thing that came out of the nuclear war
like all right how do we respond if we
get new do we incidentally start nuking
or if we're attacked
do we instantly reality retaliate and
they basically ran this through like a
like a wargames processor of like
alright how do we how do you function in
like a society where there's potentially
hostile people and basically if what it
boiled down to is you get mutually
assured destruction and pretty much like
or or you get overpowered in basically
every scenario except for one which is
the one where you you actually basically
randomly forgive it's all about being
able to like you know defend yourself
but also those moments where you are
willing to just simply like
something bad happened to you so to
speak and not not go after the source of
that contest probably what it looks like
to a computer is randomization yeah but
to humans it's like obviously probably
emotional it's very emotional and
everything like that but like you know
adding that random element of
forgiveness into those interactions
unlike a like a regular basis is what
kind of it's what resets the
interactions if you left to go to the
extremes like the in those in the
computations they basically have the two
extremes they have like the always
retaliate one and then there's like the
Jesus one which is never retaliate the
Jesus one obviously gets murdered yeah
at the end of the day no matter what
like and so if you go in your day to day
life doing that hole I'll always be
forgiving always be like it's like you
will be penniless or dead
you know and then the always retaliate
one is basically the same exact setup
because these either people walk all
over you or you cause so much of a fight
that everyone attacks you right and so
it's that it's that weird balance of of
but specifically it's the random
forgiveness element that like makes it
succeed it's interesting yeah that's my
theory it's a game theory there's a
there's actually a really cool website I
should find the link for it that
actually allows you to basically run all
the simulations basically of this and
they just straight up it's like all
right we have 300 actors in this
simulation you can choose a role here of
like howdy how do you want to respond to
situations and you get to see basically
how that works over multiple iterations
so my friend got a PhD in that's in game
theory no and then he got a graduate
degree he studied mathematics and then
he got a graduate degree and then he got
a PhD in game theory and now he works I
can't say who he works for but he works
for a major accounting firm that does
this for corporations and government
well where they they're like hey um
we're thinking about doing this with
these assets and then he runs basically
a game theory analysis of it where he's
like okay well if you do that with these
assets this company or government has
these in these assets and they'll be
likely to do this and then like here are
your scenarios and then he plays those
out basically for people that is what a
career yes yes crazy game of five things
that's cool well hopefully we can find
that and put it in the description of
this video right here it's called the
evolution or us okay and it's really
cool it so you can go to encase dot me
and see a SEO Emmy
yeah and then basically pull it up and
you get to try it out right there
whether you want to cheat or cooperate
it's like your first option and it
starts but it basically runs you through
all these simulations of basically yeah
decision-making it's really cool huh
wow that was an intense first ever
patreon livestream podcast
yeah really fun I feel like
specialist well I don't I mean I feel
special having these patrons yes how I
feel
for what oh man maybe hey OH do you
support any charities hey did you get
the email from the gear squad dude oh
yeah with the robotics yeah oh yeah
should we should we definitely show you
should do that well they'll put our logo
on their robot heck yes
it's like I uh what is it in the UK it's
a mid-level robotics team with Robotics
Competition school school kids I was I
was in Robotics Club in high school it's
great and look at you now you're
building robots on drones to shoot nerf
darts coming out hopefully I'm just glad
that I haven't destroyed anything
everything works independently but now I
don't have a pen that I can reprogram to
put out five volts without my
DGI air unit not working this is super
esoteric stuff that 99% of you won't get
so I apologize but working all weekend
on this thing again
alright guys well thank you for joining
you guys please continue to let us know
about the website and thank you $3 tier
people for now joining us in the
livestream welcome to one of the best
things we've been doing with our patrons
which is just hanging out with you guys
every month and welcome to doing it in
the new way where we're gonna be doing
it occasionally maybe more maybe less as
a podcast and if you're interested in
that if you're listening to this podcast
and you're interested in that website
you can either sign up through the $5
tier on patreon or you can just sign up
directly through the website please help
us beta test it if you guys are croûtons
true tones and you want to see where
this whole crazy experiment goes
definitely let us know instead of the
website and of course make sure you call
your mom on Mother's Day and pay your
taxes and do your homework
yeah but make sure you write everything
off yeah well I'll keep ya keep the
receipts not too much though yeah not
too much just a little bit just a little
extra just enough oh you want to answer
one more well one question was like we
should do a one wheel VFX video like
dude we've already done
[Music]